- [Patrick Mahomes:] SICK AIR. IT’S LIKE I THREW YOU UP THERE MYSELF.
- What’s up, football nerds?
- What’s up, foot—oh wait, is Rodgers already being the competitive bully?
- Come on, we’re all MVPs here.
- Uh...
- YOU WANT MINE? I’M ABOUT TO GET ANOTHER.
- Russ here is his generation’s Drew Brees.
Great player but someone’s always better.
- HEY, RUSS. I MADE US JACKETS.
- Let’s race. Winner gets control of the mountain.
Loser never comes back.
- What? No.
- Losers just wait until next year, man
- NEXT YEAR?! WHERE?
- ON YOUR MARK, GET SET. HUT HUT.
- Come on, Aaron. Remember why you are racing…
F--k the Packers. I’ll prove them wrong by winning them a lot of games.
- Nice try, but I upgraded my weapons.
- DO YOU GUYS THINK ANALYTICS ENRICHENS SPORT OR CHEAPENS IT?
- [Lamar Jackson:] Russ has the lead, but Rodgers and Brady are keeping up.
- Hey, Lamar, come join the rest of the OK QBs!
Derek’s doing a poetry reading.
- Coach screams, screams, screams, but I dream, dream, dream.
I want to go far, but I’m just another used carr.
- [Together:] Hard snap, hard snap, hard snap.
- NO. MY BOARD. BUT MY DEFENSE REINFORCED IT.
- We have to support Russ with a strong—
OH, WAIT. THE JETS ARE ON. Haha, look at Gase!
- Yo, I think something’s seriously wrong with your situation.
- With Old Spice Triple Protection Sweat Defense, I’m unstoppable.
- Hey, can I try that?
- Uh, sure.
- DELAY OF GAME!
HOLDING!
FACE MASK!
INTENTIONAL GROUNDING. Oh, I haven’t even broken a sweat!
Everyone, I am SO sorry about this. He’s got Triple Protection.
- [Lamar:] It looks like it's now a race between Rodgers and Mahomes.
- You know I also won MVP once—
- THAT'S NOT HELPING.
- Watch out for me, household name DALVIN COOK.
- Do you smell what the Dalvin is—
Oh wait, this is straight-up just a cliff.
- Man, did he not see last year’s episode?
- IS ANYONE ELSE HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE WIFI?
- I could actually win. Take that, Dad. I mean, Belichick. I mean, Arians.
- Yo, what up, man? Wanna see me make something out of nothing?
- That child is going to die.
- I knew you were down there somewhere.
- NO. MORE. NEW PEOPLE.
- HEY GUYS, HAVE YOU SEEN ALL THIS SNOW?
IT’S LIKE BUFFALO IN THE SUMMER!
- NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO—
- Uh-oh. Brady released an avalanche of bad takes.
- Big Ben deserves MVP.
- Ryan Tannehill though.
- Give it to Alex Smith for what he’s come back from.
- NO. THIS IS MY YEAR.
- [Together:] I will win MVP!
- Wow, who woulda thought, me, Josh Allen hanging in with the big boys?!
- Wait, where’s Mahomes?
- DID YOU ALL DO A SPLIT-SCREEN WITHOUT ME?!
- Goodell deserves MVP for putting on a season.
- And let's thank. Baker for the SNickerdoodles, yeah.
- They're gluten f--king free, baby.
- So thoughtful. Later on, Kirk will singus a song.
- I'm going to scream a Creed song at you all!
- That sounds delightful.
- But first, a poem from me.
I'm a Lion to myself.